the Emmy award-winning actor from the
hit HBO show berry which can be seen
right after Game of Thrones Sunday
nights at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time Bill
Hader good to see you sir
by the way nice spot for the show right
but after in between between games last
season's of games in the veep yeah it's
kind of a great that's that's good stuff
yeah we don't have to pay off to do that
sort of no I just hey I remember they
they kind of just HBO just kind of told
us that in the most nonchalant way
they're like yes you guys are gonna be
airing here and it'll be like Game of
Thrones veep last season's o show and
then they kept talking about something
else and right Alec Berg and I were like
wait what that works
excuse me yeah where do we start yes yes
yes yes yeah I know and you were just
saying that your next episode of Barry
yeah mrs. v is crazy yeah we have an
episode coming up I don't want to ruin
anything for people who didn't see last
week's right it ended on this kind of
twist mmm Barry has to go do this thing
and it's the episodes pretty insane so
we're excited because next week's game
of Thrones is gonna be amazing too right
oh that's good that's what happens when
you're in an Emmy well right that's how
it works exactly that's how it works
again let's get into this a little bit
here so Barry is a hit man who's trying
to get away from that world by becoming
an actor yeah and the world will not let
him yeah do it and it is just amazing
the show is truly amazing you're great
in it where did it come from why did you
choose this as a show for you to do well
when after I finished Sarah alive I
moved to LA and I just took a bunch of
meetings and I went into HBO and they
said well what do you want to do and I
love HBO I'd love to do the show with
you guys and you have an idea and I was
like no I don't have an idea right and
they said well is there anybody you like
and I had and my agent he reps Alec Berg
and now at Berg and I had met briefly
and I was like well I love how at Berg
and they said well
great well why don't you get together
with him so we sat down he was writing
Silicon Valley right and we would meet
for breakfast
fresh off of Curb Your Enthusiasm and
then he was doing Silicon Valley so
before he would go in the writers room
in Silicon Valley once a week he would
have breakfast with me down the street
from the writers room and we would talk
ideas and after about a month and a half
we were getting frustrated cuz
everything was kind of slice of life and
I go I'd like to have something as like
real stakes to it mm-hmm
there's all the biggest days for life
and death and I said what if I played a
hitman and Alec went oh no I hate hitman
he's like there's more he said hit man's
like dog catcher it's like it's like a
thing that's in movies more than they
were in real life sure so he was like
man let's not do hitman and then I was
like nobody's gonna be me and he was
like oh that could be funny it's you as
like a you know right like you being
yourself and I think very quickly we
thought what if he was an act he wanted
to be an actor I don't know why we were
like what if you took an acting class to
like learn how to be a human being right
because all this murder and we were kind
of like Oh what if like you know the
William money from Unforgiven or Travis
Bickle tried to find salvation and
redemption through the people and
waiting for Guffman what if he got with
those people and tried to learn how to
behave again because all these years of
murdering people and what it's done to
his soul and everything and and what if
he can that was his therapy and a way of
you know that he could be somehow
redeemed through art well I was gonna
ask you who your character I guess was
based on in previous pop culture worlds
and so Willy money who's yeah Eastwood
from Unforgiven which to me is like the
perfect Western yeah but for old-school
Western people might hear that and think
otherwise I love that movie Alex and I
went and saw it in the theater while we
were writing the no clear season yet
played they played it again at the I
pick in Westwood and we gotta go and we
win we walked out we're like yeah I
think we could do that but with a lot of
jokes let's do that tone but with jokes
and and so yeah Anna
this season a few late you know tax
driver that the tax driver unforgiven
thing is very evident through this
season you know that comparison or
whatever well the comparison I have I
got bill hader here on the Rich Eisen
show the comparison for me is Walter
White yeah from Breaking Bad and and not
because it's a nice guy who breaks bad
because of circumstances it's because on
occasion I'm watching your character I'm
rooting for you one minute and the next
minute I am just like this bastard I
can't yeah he's right he does some awful
things that when it comes to it like
where's the nice guy the nice
sensibility of the guy who wants to get
out of that world but keeps on making
choices to stay in it even though
sometime the choices are so awful yeah
we're talking about that or it was the
breaking good type thing bad guys gonna
be good right yeah that was one someone
said that in an article and I was like
oh yeah I mean but in definitely
Breaking Bad I was a big fan of that
show like the idea of trying to keep two
worlds separate and right but this guy
thinking what if is this all I'm good at
you know we're you know a lot of those
shows what I loved about Breaking Bad
and Sopranos it was almost like this
wish fulfillment of like you could
relate so well to these people right you
could relate to them and then be like
what if you know I was in a dead-end job
and everything and you know what if I
just became a drug dealer made a bunch
of money and you know that idea
mm-hm and I and Alec and I talked about
that and I go what yeah I've seen that
and it's been done so well you know this
could be like the opposite of that of a
guy who's so bad that he's trying to get
in tune and find some sort of redemption
another person others Scorsese maybe be
talked about was some Raging Bull you
know it's like that feeling of
redemption of like this guy who's just
he's not a very good guy right you know
trying to find some sort of hope or
glimmer and and and and and and the idea
that he's a very self aware of how bad
he is you know and trying to you know
just like I you know this idea that I
was put on this earth to kill people
right the only thing I'm good at is
killing people like the only thing
naturally good at is that I hope that's
not it that's not my lot in life so it's
a comedy I know I say stop Bill Hader
here on the Rich Eisen show and and a
lot of the comedy does come from a lot
of the the acting classes and choose as
the acting coach to cast Henry Winkler
who won also yeah for his work in Isis
guys in the world what was it like when
he walked in did you audition here yeah
he read for us he came in and read and I
was like you know you go into the
casting office and there's a bunch of
guys you know what their script you know
pages the sides ready to go and there's
Henry Winkler and I'm like you know you
didn't know he was coming in I I we had
talked about him my and my casting
director Sherry Thomas and I said you
know who'd be great for Cousteau is
Henry Winkler I didn't know he was gonna
read necessarily she thought it was
gonna be like a meeting that when he
came in I was so nervous Alec and I both
were just wait just so starstruck by him
and then he was awesome and then we did
the terrible thing that you know you do
to actors you go you were great can you
come in and read again you know I wrote
a new scene for us to do and Henry was
like Fonzie for crime comedy he's TV
he's right he does like that's the first
image of television I can remember as a
kid
rice was Fonzie right and yeah I mean
and he does it sometimes he'll talk
about something that he'll go into
Fonzie for a second come on and I'll go
Alec Berg was behind me he was talking
about something and yeah fun in a Fonzie
Henry was like oh we couldn't leave he
goes me in Ron Howard and some of the
guys from the show we were trying to
leave a we did a signing and we were
trying to leave this mall in Dallas and
people with lettuce ters so he's like I
came out as Fonz you know an eight but
like the Red Sea he said he did that
when he did it I'm like this now my Berg
was behind me and Alec he's not the most
a few severe eight like and I went oh
you forget bonzi so he did it and we all
and I just learned that Mike can you be
like I can't believe we were like two
little kids you know good just
disappointed that he doesn't actually
turn on the lights but just hitting a
wall yeah I know
No well we were shooting a scene of
really emotional scene this season and I
was directing Henry and it's this really
rough scene for him and and in the
middle of it I'm kind of again it's like
what we were just doing talking about
kind of a darkness of mm-hm and he
trimmed looks around and he goes you
know this is the stage we're a paramount
stage 19 he goes this is where we did
happy days I was like wait what and like
and then our camera operator is like
wait what wait what this is what you
guys did happy days like we did happy
days and we're like wait and we just
everything stopped and we're like where
where was it where was a jukebox yeah
and the whole thing stopped
we just stopped shooting we stopped
doing everything he's like so yeah the
jukebox would be here and then I would
do and then why you know and he just
explained everything
my head was exploding yeah where Tom
Bosley's craft service table was like
that is where Tom would yell it that's
the he tonight oh man bill hader here on
the Rich Eisen show your favorite
character you did on SNL would be what
if you could just like wave a wand and
say I'll go by obviously they're having
you back all the time now but if you
could do it again a lot of favorite ones
I love doing the Vincent Price specials
Vincent Price love doing Keith Morrison
the date line I could just read anything
from him and it would just sound creepy
he said something move it was it's not
this there was something like a guy he
says like say yeah your dad got shot in
the face
[Laughter]
I must have been a while right in front
where did Vincent Price come from like
this is a big Vincent Price fan and then
I remembered it around the table you
know that Murray and I talked about it
right and we decided to do it and and
for Thanksgiving it was like this weird
Thanksgiving special I remember right
before I came out to do it Lauren
Michaels goes it was my third or fourth
show I was terrified and he went I like
this but why now why now do we do
Vincent Price but but people seem to
like it and that one was fun Keith
Morrison was fun
then he vedecci the Italian talk-show
host was fun where did was that born out
of just I was in line to see AI the
movie ai okay at the Mann's Chinese and
there was a guy in front of us talking
like that and he was it was he was kind
of lecherous Italian guy he was hitting
on these two like you know 18 year old
girls and he was like I buy you gelato
gelato you want you're not a robot boy
and so the whole movie I was making my
friends laugh it's being itchy break see
me break you don't like him no more and
I was just like poke around and I was
just doing it the whole movie to make my
two friends laugh and then I was like I
should probably and then when I met a
manager and she was what can you do
impressions and I was like no I'd never
really thought about doing impressions
of famous people and she goes well do
you do a voice anything I went what is
this guy this Italian guy I'm about a
game dope on a hunch goes okay we could
work with that and that became my
audition my audition was that guy for a
scene impressions yeah so it was like
Vinny vedecci the Italian guy was
auditioning for SNL right Thank You
Laura in law this is so amazing you know
and he was then he would do a bunch of
impressions so who was Bill Hader here
in the Rich Eisen show who who did where
did Stefan come from did that uh was
that that came from
two things john mulaney wrote that with
me and John
I deserved a lot of credit for Stefan
because he wrote so much of the rhythm
of that and the specifics of it and
clearly I found it funny because I
laughed every time we did it I don't
think we ever did it where I didn't
laugh and it came from an email he got
describing a club and it was this guy
was trying to get John dick it was like
a club promoter and John was at his desk
and goes read this email this is email I
just got
and it was you know this thing has
everything that you know that this club
has everything the hottest club in New
York is blank and it had that thing to
it and one of the things was a roomful
of broken glass and we started laughing
and then and then I and then I would go
to a coffee shop and um Chelsea on my
way to work and there was a guy that
barista there was kind of like that you
know and the stephane was yeah a member
one time he said I live like on the
lower Lower East Side we're looking at a
photograph of Stephon right now yeah I
love Stefan but I always feel bad cuz I
don't I've never done it without
breaking because John will put in
different things or he'll tell me as I'm
walking out and it's just like throwing
stuff at me and when I hosted last John
came out and this shy his lawyer who's
also a piss artist yeah and and he came
in and he this is all john and john
whispered and he comes out and and he i
thought he was gonna do it kind of like
and the stefan boys like hey Stefan or
what he was hello Stefan he goes hello
Stefan hello everyone
and then he whispered in my ear he goes
I have something to tell you and he just
whispers in my ear my girlfriend works
at Yoshi Noah beef ball
just to like it's just punching me in
the face he's like hey by the way my
girl I'll tell you I know you're not
supposed to laugh at this stuff and
break in the middle of a scene but
that's every time yeah the first time
was we had a club promoter named amnesia
bermed bernstein and it didn't really
get anything and then he goes and major
Bernstein didn't really get anything and
he goes I'll change it to something else
and then as I was walking out he was a
changed him he should Bernstein to
galeota and I started laughing so the
minute I roll out I'm like all right the
other one that made me laugh
he said he'll change little things we
had a we had written a also at the club
was a two year old Ultimate Fighter
Julie lips Jackson he's got fists like
empanadas and he's addicted to ecstasy
that's what we were and then he wrote so
it was like two-year-old a two-year-old
Ultimate Fighter drooly lips Jackson
he's got fists like and he's got fists
like empanadas and they turned the cue
card it said he's my behind the cue
cards past me I could see him in
Sandberg that's what I mean the last
thing I will bring up too is I would pay
okay I would pay to be able to if I'm
driving around here and and my phone is
giving me directions to have your
californians oh yeah deliver the direct
I would pay to change the voice you know
I can change it from Australian or
British or whatever that'd be fun yeah
that's that's all that's fred armisen
and a guy named Shane Fred Armisen and a
guy named James Anderson and that's a
bit that Fred and Keenan and I used to
do when we get back from LA had me I
just got back from LA and it's like
cool man how'd you get to your hotel
that's like well I went down Sunset took
a left on La Cienega and then took that
all the way down and took a ride on
Venice and then [ __ ] you know we was
like always say how we got places and
then he made it a soap opera which
really made me laugh and Frank came out
to me goes I did our bit it's a soap
opera I would just pay to have you just
say you make a right and then you know
sometimes you just miss the right like
and hearing your voice spaces of the
back up yes I back up rerouting you know
just make some money on this I'm just
saying I'm just saying you can't hey
Bill love it when you come on the show
things Barry's airing Sunday by the way
after the Battle of Winterfell as you
just mentioned season five meaning
you're sick second season fifth episode
is this is the craziest one yet yeah
there's a good episode I'm loved and
watching it really a Liam check out
Barry on HBO Sunday nights 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app